tot mitten in der Gassi Runde ein Thema
was uns beschäftigt 12 Hunde sterben
nach einem Spaziergang durch den noblen
bonifatiuspark in Frankfurt in Hessen
die Tiere wurden gezielt getötet und das
mit Heroin
dygo Ruby Blacky body Lucy fünf kleine
Opfer eines so großen Verbrechens diese
Hunde sie wurden tödlich vergiftet beim
Spielen beim Gassi gehen vergiftet von
Heroin hundeköder
Tatort das Frankfurter Nobelviertel
Rietberg hier verteilt ein Unbekannter
die Giftköder 30 Tiere werden vergiftet
12 Hunde sterben emanueles Hund lucy ist
eines der giftköderopfer der
Hundebesitzer schildert uns die
Geschehnisse des Vergangenen freitags
dieses grausamen morgens noch ein Weg
nach Hause haben wir bemerkt es
irgendwas stimmt nicht aber vielleicht
haben Sie auch Hunger sie war extrem
durstig und hatte innerhalb kürzester
Zeit ihren ganzen Napf getrunken und
dann ist sie rumgerannt rumgerannt ich
merkte das stimmt was nicht in großer
Sorge fährt Emanuele in die Tierklinik
versucht seine Hündin zu retten sie
wurde mir aus der Hand genommen und das
war das letzte mal da hat sich sie
gesehen hatte doch es ist zu spät die
kleine Lucy stirbt wenig später in der
Klinik
ein Hundebesitzer findet die Köder
bringt sie zum Tierarzt und lässt die
tödlichen Köder untersuchen das Ergebnis
es ist unfassbar der Hundehasser mischt
Heroin und am Termine in die Köder
verteilt sie in der Stadt um gezielt
Hunde zu töten auch Mark Bees Hund Buddy
frisst am Freitag einen der Heroin
Giftköder des hundehassers als wenn er
auf Drogen wär als Speed ist er durch
das Haus gerannt wie ein wie ein Wilder
durchs Stockwerk hoch runter über die
Couch durch komplette Stockwerk und dann
den Hund genommen gleich sofort zum
Tierarzt gefahren im Kofferraum nur
gesehen wir wir
zusammengesackt ist kommen beim Tierarzt
an Macht direktklappe auf und er fällt
mir quasi aus dem Auto raus drei Stunden
später stirbt der kleine Buddy der
Schatz der Familie beim Tierarzt und
auch Buddies bester Freund Blacky wird
von den Giftködern tödlich vergiftet
am Sonntag kommen die Familien der zwölf
kleinen Opfer zu einer Mahnwache
zusammen nehmen Anteil und sind sich
gegenseitig eine Stütze doch die Fragen
bleiben wieso wer hasst unschuldige
Hunde so sehr dass er sie mit einem
Drogencocktail vergiftet diese Fragen
versucht jetzt auch die Kripo Frankfurt
zu klären die Beamten ermitteln unter
Hochdruck den Frankfurter Hundehasser zu
finden und die Hunde zu schützen
[Musik]
ja das sind Familienmitglieder die jetzt
einfach fehlen es ist so so traurig wer
hat so ein Hass auf Tiere und vor allem
wie kann man die Tiere schützen wir
sprechen jetzt mit Tiertrainer David
Lenneper heleneper ja wie kann man die
Hunde trainieren dass die solche Köder
solche tödlichen Köder nicht essen
ich bin immer noch hier von diesem
Beitrag den ich gerade gesehen habe
Wahnsinn welche Ausmaße das mittlerweile
annimmt also es gibt nicht oder es gibt
leider nicht den den Trick a oder Trick
B den man anwenden kann es ist immer
wichtig dass man eine gute Bindung und
Beziehung hat und das mit dem Hund zu
früh wie möglich
ein absolut guten Rückruf beibringt und
ihm auch beibringt vielleicht auch
verschiedene Sachen einfach anzuzeigen
das ist ein sehr vielseitiges und und
groß angelegtes Training es gibt auch
die Möglichkeit dem Hund ein ganz
sicheres auskommando beizubringen das
sind alles Dinge die sollte man so früh
wie möglich schon beginnen das heißt
nicht dass ältere Hunde das nicht auch
aber das sind so so Grundbasis Sachen
die man die man frühzeitig schon
trainieren sollte also Rückruf ein
auskommando das sind schon mal wichtige
Dinge die man auf jeden Fall in Angriff
nehmen sollte unabhängig vom Giftköder
die Erziehung von Hunden also wichtig
gibt es da Unterschiede zwischen den
Hunderassen
ja natürlich gibt es Hunderassen die
sehr darauf fixiert sind alles
aufzunehmen also wenn wir über den
typischen Labrador sprechen der der
gerne auch dafür bereit steht alles zu
fressen was was rum liegt mit dem ist
das natürlich ein bisschen schwieriger
auch zu trainieren weil man sehr sehr
schnell sein muss und man ja auch nicht
auf diesen Moment wartet
wo es vielleicht schon passiert ist
sondern da viel viel früher eingreifen
muss was vielleicht eine andere Rasse im
hütehundebereich die vielleicht gar
nicht so fresaffin sind und dann
vielleicht auch Dinge die die
schmackhaft sind dann auch am Wegesrand
liegen lassen das Problem bei den ganzen
Sachen ist tatsächlich das jetzt nicht
wie in dem Fall eben mit mit Heroin
sondern auch Sachen wie Rattengift für
einen Hund oftmals sehr Geschmackssachen
sind das heißt die Hunde suchen quasi
auch nach diesen Mitteln weil sie sagen
das schmeckt ihnen wunderbar also ihm
ist natürlich nicht bewusst dass das
Ganze giftig ist
wie kann ich denn erkennen dass mein
Hunden Giftköder gegessen hat und was
muss ich dann überhaupt tun damit meinen
Tieren Überlebenschance hat
also es ist manchmal gar nicht so
einfach weil viele Hunde sich einfach
auch sehr ruhig zurückziehen sich auf
ihren Schlafplatz begeben aber manchmal
und so haben es die die Menschen ja auch
im Beitrag berichtet fällt es einfach
auf das heißt die Hunde werden unruhig
die Hunde fangen an zu hecheln die Hunde
bekommen Stress manche übergeben sich
manche versuchen zu würgen manche
bekommen schüttelanfälle das ist ganz
unterschiedlich wichtig ist dass ich
immer auf mein Bauchgefühl vertraue und
einfach schaue was ist anders beim Hund
und lieber fahre ich einmal mehr zum
Tierarzt als einmal zu wenig und was mir
immer ganz wichtig ist dass ich
tatsächlich ich habe immer
kohlekompreten dabei das was wir unseren
Kindern das was wir uns selber in
durchfallsituation vielleicht schon mal
geben in einem Fall wo ich denke dass
eine Vergiftung stattfinden könnte oder
stattgefunden hat gebe ich meinem Hund
meinetwegen die ganze Packung
kohlekompreten ein das ist ein
natürlicher Stoff der kann nicht
überdosiert werden aber er bindet die
Giftstoffe im Körper das heißt nicht
dass der Hund dann keine Vergiftung mehr
hat das bringt mir eventuell ein
bisschen Zeit um dann auch wieder zum
Tierarzt zu fahren
vielen Dank für das Gespräch David
Lenneper
[Musik]